this is why i never had kids
that might be one of the coolest things
that's ever happened to me but don't
ever do that again
what up guys
uh this is our first day on the
spiderman no way home press tour
we're about to watch the new trailer
which comes out soon
i'm pretty excited interesting
all right we ready yeah let's go i'm
quite nervous actually
[Music]
i've only had one week were you really
in times square where am i like yeah
we were on that bridge there was when
you drove how difficult that bridge was
to land
oh
was crazy in that one
i love this one
it's gonna be so sick people are gonna
lose their minds hello whoa
oh
when we did that i just was running
out of time
what's your name
i hope that's in there yeah for sure
we need to send them back oh so the suit
looks sick
it's christmas
over flying i'm not at first darkness
hmm well i don't know oh my gosh
yeah because it's always a summery movie
it's always come out in june right right
get it oh
[Laughter]
oh
that was so adorbs
where's the this is all my fault i can't
save everyone yes you can you can say
that
bro do it my god
people are going to go crazy when they
see that bit oh my goodness what's
happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
oh my goodness people are not ready this
is a very this is that's quite stressful
honestly like it's i got scared i know
you guys are alive
high stakes high stakes literally well
guys that was the trailer for spider-man
no way home it comes out
it's really soon yeah like it comes out
in a few days oh it comes out tomorrow
it comes out tomorrow so this will
probably come out after that yeah so you
could release this first yeah
first look
it's just us
all right anyway that was fun yeah see
you guys